c'est en longeant comme ça une voie
ferrée un peu au hasard qu'elle a
rencontré celle qui allait devenir
l'héroïne de son dernier film elle c'est
mélanie loisel une jeune documentariste
tourangelle en 2013 elle a réalisé le
portrait d'une garde barrière dont la
vie a basculé le jour où la sncf a
décidé d'automatiser son passage à lévis
à 62 ans claudine et garde-barrière à
joué-lès-tours un jour une jeune
documentariste entre dans sa guérite
entre les deux femmes c'est le coup de
foudre cinématographique
oh moi au delà de la question de l'eau
travail automatisés ou mécanisée c'était
aussi la question du rapport au travail
et du sentiment de l'utilité qu'on peut
avoir quand on fait un travail et elle
c'était très fort en fait à cet endroit
là parce que finalement ça paraît
justement très désuet très lointain
durant 11 mois
mélanie capturent chaque petite scène du
quotidien de la sexagénaire un quotidien
fait de longs moments de solitude
entrecoupés de rencontre je connais très
bien s'est passé à la fois de retour est
ce que parce que c'est un lieu à nos
dents et c'est ça qui m'intéressait mais
c'était voilà c'était des choses banales
en fait quelqu'un qui amène à un paon
chocolat à cette femme des enfants qui
traversent qui lui font des signes
enfin tout se passait dans des moments
très très infime et sa reposait sur pas
grand chose en fait elle a décidé
qu'elle donnait plus la main et elle a
décidé bas qu'elle savait faire la route
seul
au bout du chemin il y avait
l'automatisation de la guérite c'était
comme en salle et la traversée elle de
façon intime
c'était un peu les montagnes russes en
fait elle voilà elle passer d'une
émotion à une autre et tout ça ça
racontait plein de choses en fait de
deux de la vie fin du cheminement en
fait de la vie la vie la vie d'êtres
moment d'être épouse de rester à la
maison
la vie sur la péniche la vie garde
barrière il m'en reste plus puant le
passage de mélanie loisel une tranche de
vie à l'état brut
dans la lignée de la célèbre émission
strip tease qu'on à faire quand on est
chômeur et qu'on n'a pas un sou en
banque
s'il vous plaît à contrôler mois
provoquer un contrôle fiscal pour tenter
d'attirer l'attention de ses proches
gérard jugnot incarne le célèbre
françois pignon du dîner de cons
d'enchères trésor d'un petit milliard
pour l'erreur affectueux
millionnaire
une voix sol et un premier album disque
d'or imany sera à bois le 16 avril pour
un apéro concert au château d'eau
non ils ont l'air de débarquer tout
droit de la nouvelle orléans les ygos
brass band une fanfare qui fera swinguer
la ferté-saint-aubin le 11 avril
prochain le cirque bidon va à la
rencontre des gens avec ces roulottes
tirées par des chevaux depuis trois ans
il est suivi dans son itinérance par le
photographe alain gaymard une exposition
pleine de poésie et d'authenticité
à découvrir jusqu'au 17 avril la semaine
prochaine vous découvrirez un nouveau
lieu culturel tourangeau baptisé le
point haut en compagnie d'une fanfare
très animé
l' orchestre du coin bon week-end à tous
sous le soleil évidemment